okay yeah i've got another big number
for you brady 1.76
times 10 to the 67. okay so let me ask
you a question can you think of a number
you know completely random number that
no one in the history of humanity has
ever thought of
and number no
i think i could do that quite easily
yeah yeah okay i agree so what would you
have to do there what would how would
you do it well i would just have to make
it big and i would just i would choose
like you know
nine or ten digits and randomly choose
those digits okay so i think nine or ten
digits is probably a bit on the low side
i think so this is what this number is
all about it's about thinking of numbers
that no one in the whole history of
humanity has ever thought of
this is an estimate that i've come up
with based on stuff that i've seen on
the internet so basically if you go to a
number that is bigger than this so pick
a random number that's bigger than this
value then there's a 99 chance
that that number has never been thought
of by anybody ever in the history of
humanity quick interjection before you
start
you told me nine to ten digits was a bit
on the low side if i choose a random ten
digit number
random
who on earth will have thought of that
in the history of humanity so there will
be some probability that so okay so you
you need to justify this clearly right
it's where this is called and i think
it's going to be something that's going
to spark a lot of debate we could argue
about whether this is a good estimate or
not i think one thing's for sure if you
if you think you can get away with a
nine digit number then i'm saying well
try a 68 digit number then
that's definitely going to be a good
ballpark so we're probably in safe
territory going this big this is
i think you're eyeballing it but anyway
okay let's see that let's see where does
it come from where's the massive problem
behind us and we can argue all day about
the assumptions that have gone into it
so the first thing you've got to ask is
is how many numbers has humanity thought
of what's the sample size of numbers
that humanity have thought of and this
is probably one bit where people are
going to really argue about about my
assumptions but i'm going to make them
and that's it you could argue how are we
defining thought of by the way just
here we go we've already started
uh well let's just okay so i'm going to
say
my assumption is going to be that a
typical person
thinks of a number every two minutes of
their waking life now that's probably an
overestimate
but i want to overestimate well we can
redo it again different number if you
want but let me go let me go for for
that right i i think i want to
overestimate because i want to be
guaranteed right that i'm in a good
place uh so let me make that my
assumption
okay so typical person life expectancy
today i think is
73.2 years how many days is that well
let's just multiply that by 365 and a
quarter how many hours that's 24 hours
but we're already awake for around two
thirds of the day so i need to factor in
two thirds and i'm saying so this is the
number of hours that a typical person
would be awake for in their lifetime and
if we say that they think of a number
every two minutes then i should multiply
by 30. now clearly i know that's
probably a bit of an overestimate people
aren't thinking about numbers as much
when they're young number five viewers
will probably think about way more
numbers obviously so
we've got to do something so this is
this is the assumption i'm going to go
with unique numbers
are we coming to that no i'm not
suggesting everybody's thinking of
different numbers we're all we most of
us are all going to think about lots of
low numbers right i'm a liverpool fan
and this is all i'm thinking about the
moment is the number four because i
think we're gonna win four trophies this
season i thought you were going to think
of four because liverpool just speak man
united four nil well there's also that
there's also that lots of fours going
off in liverpool at the moment anyway so
so let's just say this is the number of
numbers that a typical person will think
of in their lifetime obviously they're
not all going to be different numbers
okay this is about i think about 12.8
million okay so now i need to multiply
it by the number of people that have
lived
so a bit of googling you see what a
recent estimate for the number of people
have ever lived is it's about 117
billion which i thought was quite
interesting actually because i've always
had this you hear people say oh there's
more people alive today than have ever
lived that's not true apparently uh it's
about 117 billion is the most recent
ballpark figure so i'm just going to
multiply this by 117 billion okay now i
know what people are going to say now is
that wasn't life expectancy less in the
past yes it was of course in the iron
age people already live until they're
about 20 or so they probably were
thinking about numbers list probably the
way of thinking a bit less you certainly
weren't thinking about graham's number
so this is the number
so i'm going to go with this so again
it's probably an overestimate for that
reason so what is this number so this
i'm going to call it n and as a ballpark
figure this is about one and a half
times ten to the eighteen which is
a quintillionaire it's one and a half
quintillion i think so what is this this
is the number of numbers
our estimate probably an overestimate
the number of numbers that humanity has
ever thought of in the whole of human
history but there's lots of duplicates
like totally a lot of those will be one
yeah yeah yeah completely yeah low yeah
vast majority is going to be a
significant proportion is going to be
one okay so we have to now think about
how are we going to guarantee ourselves
a number that no one's ever thought of
so what we're going to say is because
this is the mathematical problem we're
interested in we've got a sample size of
size
one and a half quintillion
okay now we could say right what's the
probability that all of that sample is
less than 10. it's going to be something
tiny right it's going to be really
negligible a random sample that big is
going to be all less than 10. you say
what's the probability that all of that
sample is less than um a trillion okay
it's still going to be a very low
probability so there's a 99 probability
that a sample this big
will be less than this what mathematical
tool did you use to come to that okay
let me show you so we first have to
think about the distribution of numbers
okay that how often they appear you know
in human thought i suppose right okay so
let's take some numbers n and let's
think about the probability distribution
of those numbers clearly small numbers
are going to appear much more regularly
than large numbers this is intuitively
obvious because of like football scores
and
house numbers and yeah just your small
numbers just crop up in everyday life
also you know also we need to put aside
sort of slight anomalous things like
years are going to appear more regularly
um
powers of 10 appear more more than their
sort of nearest neighbors and so on and
so forth so we're really interested in
sort of random numbers and looking over
it on on sort of trends i saw somewhere
that the number 666 appears much more
regularly than those numbers around you
i expect so there's all that going on
but i want to sort of sweep that onto
the car but that's not what we're
interested in we're interested in
general trends so it's clear that it's
going to fall with the size of the
number question is how fast does it fall
now you might think i know you've done
videos about benford's law before the
fall office goes like one over n i'm not
going to use that
and the reason is is well there's two
reasons actually if i assume it's one
over n and this this i can't normalize
this probability these probabilities
can't be added to one they they always
hit infinity
so so
i i don't want that so it's clear to me
that at some stage a very big numbers
it's got to drop off more quickly and i
did find there is a paper from 2005 i
think it is where they look at the
distribution of numbers on the internet
random numbers and they also look at
powers of 10 but they also look at sort
of random numbers and what they find is
the falloff is going like 1 over n to
the 1.3 that's actually good that's
faster than benford's law so it's
dropping quicker it means we can
normalize this as well so i want to
think about
sets of numbers that
aren't as big as a certain value okay so
this is telling me the distribution of
all the numbers but what i need to think
about now is what's called the
cumulative
distribution so i want to take a given
number
n star say and i want to ask
what is the probability that a random
number is less than this n star n star
might be 10 it might be 20 it might be a
billion whatever what's the probability
that a randomly picked number is less
than that value well how do i calculate
that
well i just have to sum up all these
probabilities
so that corresponds to the area under
the curve and i can figure out what that
is with a bit of calculus we don't need
to do it now but it's going to be
the answer i get is 1 minus n star to
the minus 0.3 this tells us the
probability that a randomly chosen
number is less than n star
okay now what's the probability that a
randomly chosen number is less than
infinity well it should be one right
yeah so what if i put n equals one n
equals infinity in there i get one so
that makes sense
what's the probability that a randomly
chosen number is less than one well it
can't be less than one we're choosing
very interested in sort of you know
positive whole numbers so i put n equals
one in there and i get zero so you can
see this sort of makes sense it's kind
of working for those cases the
probability that a random number is less
than 10 is about a half in this okay but
this is only one number
right we've got one and a half
quintillion of these guys to worry about
okay so let's think about our one and a
half quintillion so let's ask a slightly
simpler question first
what if i take
um one and a half quintillion numbers
and i demanded that all less than ten
what's the probability that they're all
less than 10 very unlikely i've just
told you that one number
has a
basically a 50 50 chance that's less
than 10 so that's 0.5
if i'm interested in n numbers or one
and a half quintillion numbers being
less than
10. i need to basically take that to
the power of what
one and a half quintillion which is
essentially zero
okay
right so this is no good so obviously
the answer is not ten we're not thinking
about 10. if i want to generalize this
now to sort of
any number n star then i just plug in
this guy so this is basically the
probability that all of our one and a
half quintillion numbers are less than n
star okay so you've got huge one and a
half considering numbers what's the
probability they're less than some
n-star whatever n-star is it's that
so now we're ready to answer our
question let me draw this as a function
of n-star well it looks something like
this
this is asymptote going towards one okay
again this makes sense because what this
is telling you if i take n star very big
then it's saying that the probability
that my
it really really is thinking starts at
graham's number the probability that my
qu you know one and a half quintillion
numbers are all less than grams number
is essentially one it's very likely if i
take n star very small the probability
that my
one and a half quintillion numbers are
all less than n star
and that's a really small number it's
essentially going to be zero so it sort
of makes sense we're interested in the
point where this crosses the 99
threshold we can calculate what that is
we just have to solve an equation the
equation we solve is this
okay and if we solve that then we get
that x is
1.76 times 10 to the 67. so let's think
about what this is telling us this tells
us that if we have a set of numbers
random numbers of one and a half
quintillion which is the amount of
numbers we think humanity is picked then
there's a 99 chance they're all going to
be less than this
okay conversely if you go beyond that
there's a 99 chance you're going to find
a number that nobody's ever thought of
okay you seem skeptical
i'm not skeptical of the mathematics but
i think your assumptions are so wrong
let's look at numbers that have 66
digits right so down one down from where
you are yeah
if you choose all the numbers in that
bracket i think there's probably maybe
one human or 10 humans that have ever
thought of the numbers
of a 66-digit number
i don't know a thousand humans maybe
have thought of a 66-digit number in
their life
i guess have you ever thought of a 66
digit number i'm always thinking of 66
did you know it's really
i don't know i mean a 99 probability i
know what you're saying it's i don't
know what's what the math comes out as
okay can we go up can we do a bit more
can we think about the future of
humanity okay okay all right all right
so
let's think of the future of humanity i
said this would be controversial right
so future of humanity now so now we have
to ask the question how many people are
going to live so we don't want to think
about numbers that nobody will ever
think of or ever use maybe maybe a
better way to ever use maybe we talk
about numbers that people are using
right so maybe you're using numbers at
once every you know 30 minutes that
could be very big and you don't have to
think of a number to use yeah maybe
that's how we should talk talk about
this yeah now you realize okay fine all
right okay so so have i used this am i
using a 66 digit number
what's an example of me using a really
big number but not thinking of it i mean
when you're doing it on a computer
somewhere and messing around that kind
of thing so we're going to do future
okay so so we have to ask how many
people are going to live
okay so so now now this is another
debate so this again is controversial
okay so there's something called the
doomsday argument which is not without
its controversy has its critics it goes
back to brandon carter cosmologist in
the 1970s he was thinking about things
like the anthropic principle the general
argument is that we don't have a special
place in human history
okay there's nothing special about where
we are
so what you could say from that is is
that there's a 99 chance that we're in
the last 99 of people
okay that seems reasonable
okay that means there's a 99 chance that
we're past the one percent point
okay so the one percent point is or so
it means there's a 99 chance that one
117 billion
is past the one percent point
okay so that means there's a 99 chance
that there's no more than 100 times
117 billion so that puts the total
number of humans
that will ever live
at less than
times 10 to the 11. so this is based on
these doomed arguments and us not being
special and blah blah blah
this would be enough a limit on the
number of humans that will ever live and
99 confidence oh it's quite scary
because this actually brings the ends of
the world quite quite rapid it's like
within i'd have to check it but it's
something like 10 to 100 000 years and
then it's all got it
so if you redo all this analysis again
then you get that 8.2 times 10 to the
73. so it's basically saying if you
choose a 74 digit number no one ever
either past future or present
in the history of humanity will think of
that number or use that number if i
choose a 74 digit number right now
yeah
that's like potentially
my number forever no one else will ever
have that i think so
if you believe a lot of these
assumptions that got into this which
might be dubious although we're saying
this is probably you know i think we can
probably agree that these are probably
over estimates if anything yeah these
are probably over estimates we could
probably bring this down quite quite
considerably right so if anyone watching
this chooses a 74-digit number randomly
it's probably theirs forever i think so
i think so and this is i mean i've been
really conservative in these assumptions
and i think you agree with that because
you're like if i think of a 12-digit
number like no one's ever thought of
that before right that's what you think
right and so so i'm coming up with much
bigger numbers
and really conservative assumptions so
yeah i'd agree i reckon if you think of
a 74-digit number totally a random don't
don't do one with 73 zeroes after it if
you do something a bit more exotic then
yeah i don't think anybody's ever going
to think of that that's just yours
forever mate
nice
if you enjoy musing about all this big
number stuff you're sure to love tony's
new book called fantastic numbers and
where to find them a cosmic quest from
zero to infinity i'll include an order
link in the video description reading
the book is like a conversation with
tony
and if you love learning check out
brilliant today's episode sponsor
all the courses on brilliant are
designed to be interactive
move things around yourself get an
intuition by being hands-on
there's mathematics physics astronomy
chemistry computer science
and of course my personal favorite the
daily challenges and there's new stuff
being added all the time
no matter your age or learning level
this is going to improve your life it's
a bit like the gym but for your brain
go to brilliant.org number five to check
them out that slash number file will
also bag you 20
off a premium subscription if you're
already a subscriber brilliant is also a
great gift for other people in your life
our thanks to them for supporting this
episode
[Music]